welcome to the Monster Hunter world  blights Weapon series sword and shield  the sword and shield combo is an  incredibly versatile and mobile weapon  choice due to its nimble nature you can  still use healing items traps and your  slinger whilst it's still drawn  [Music]  jool blades  the tool blades can overwhelm monsters  with a flurry of vicious attacks  activating demon mode will unleash their  true potential and bestow the ability to  unleash a feral assault  longsword  the longsword is a swift agile weapon  capable of lengthy and extended combos  you can even raise your attack power by  using a spirit blade and unleash this  weapons ultimate power light Boger the  light snow gun is a long ranged weapon  that specializes in high mobility and  rapid fire arms the powerful wave and  blast this weapon is a tried and tested  means of supporting your hunting party